where this clothing hygiene education in
a school in Uganda this is no ordinary
teacher she's the director of a startup
company a new kind of sanitary pad is
passed from one girl to the next this
pad is biodegradable and affordable for
the girls according to a UNESCO report
one in 10 girls in sub-saharan Africa
skipped school during her menstrual
cycle and in Uganda a pack of sanitary
pads costs almost half of the minimum
wage per month startup company EcoSmart
pads was founded by women
the founders know what many girls in
Africa have to go through when you go to
schools you'd be surprised to know that
some will miss school because they are
going through a menstrual period the
four days of their master period they do
not have the right materials to use they
are so embarrassed to be in public
because they'll stay in their dresses
and everyone will laugh at them so they
choose to stay at home the material used
is a byproduct of sugarcane processing
you have the sugarcane and the water
that is already steamed coming in here
so what you're doing is boiling that
sugarcane residue mainly to remove the
sugar content and to soften it the
material is cheap to produce and because
they have the support of local
organizations the price of these
sanitary pads is just half that of
normal ones after you use the seeds to
sieve out the paper altogether with the
fiber
so that water drains through the field
and after this process you're taking it
for drying back at the school the girls
provide important feedback to the
company about their needs we know now
realize that we are supposed to produce
a pad that is they in different sizes
that is able to accommodate four I hello
like fellow flowing girl and high flows
and it has also shown us that you should
produce a part that is that is
comfortable for these girls and a part
that is affordable those eco pods they
will help those Eagles house because
some girls they are poor they don't have
money to buy other pods by 2016 more
than 55,000 biodegradable eco pads had
been provided to Uganda and schoolgirls
that keeps them in school and protects
the environment
[Music]